over the past 11 years i'd uh i'd often
grab a camera crew and hang out with my
wonderful staff including my trusted
assistant
sona
here are some highlights you got my
lunch today yeah
i didn't eat lunch today oh evan
was told today to go get conan's lunch
absolutely i did that
but conan didn't eat lunch conan didn't
even order lunch i spoke with sona
sauna sometimes in order to get things
done
quickly for me i might use your name
to like light a fire what else are you
doing
for yourself where you use my name
did you send this email out to the
entire staff
i know this is a complete abuse of hey
everybody but if you stole my
gigolos mug i'm going to find you
and destroy you did you send that uh yes
i did
first of all what's a gigolo's mug uh
gigolos is a show on
showtime and it says gigolos on one side
and on the other it says working stiff
stiff like a joke yes i think so
what's the joke it's like
like a like it's a stiff like a penis
is it possible you had a little drinky
winky and maybe misplaced it
i had a drinky like this morning i had a
drinky winky do you ever drink at work
let's just leave it alone do you have
any theories about what happened to the
monk people just take [ __ ] all the time
what do you mean people steal stuff
you've had stuff stolen i made a mark
to prove if someone was stealing my
booze what kind of office is this
do you keep alcohol on your desk no i
should though probably no why should you
make the day more fun okay
could you take her alcohol now oh
because i'm irish
no i didn't take her alcohol i i'm not a
big drinker
this is a crossword puzzle and it was
sitting on your desk so you were doing a
crossword puzzle on your desk
don't you can't lie in front of the
camera if you can't lie
then yes i was okay
what are you stuck on if i say it and
then you know this ends up
on the thing then people are gonna think
i'm stupid for not knowing it so i just
don't wanna
okay okay a three-letter word for
vehicle that starts with c
is car
billy can you ask sona to bring me a
half calf vanilla latte with skim milk
all right
wait a minute sona this is tea just
drink it [ __ ]
why is this thing why is this thing open
it doesn't close
i could fix this if you want what can
you
oh my god
[Applause]
how about a hummer want to get a hummer
it needs so much gas
they make a model that only runs on
rainforest wood
that's not true okay a good improv
partner
more with conan son is improv when we
come back
well i'm in a candy shop now yeah now
imagine we're at the office okay and
you're wearing that and there's like a
call
uh steven spielberg on line one steven
spielberg wouldn't call you
[Applause]
[Music]
i mean he won't just he just won't have
that much drama
sony your natural speaking voice is
driving them that way
i think sauna would be easy to find a
match for
good job in america well good job
my boss is going to be dick
[Applause]
it's not nice i had something delivered
to your house
that it felt high time to recognize
someone who's doing a killer job
wait a minute i won i got employee of
the month
if you're just tuning in uh kumail
nanjiani not able uh
yeah tonight at what point did you
realize you were going to be the guest
on the show tonight and not kumail
nanjiani i think
right when i was walking in like when
you called my name i was like oh [ __ ]
they really ran out of stuff to do
you're looking for a house right now can
i put you on the spot
can you buy me a house
so tell me what's going on with you guys
i think that there is a mental block i
have about helping him
she has a mental block against helping
me she's my assistant
let's understand why i think uh some
positive reinforcement would
be nice and also it'd be great if he
stopped being so passive-aggressive
all the time i'm not passive aggressive
these are slanders he goes into
character when he doesn't want to
address
reality sometimes this is not true
i disagree he does too many bits
do you see the bits that he this never
stops it never
the bits are never ending like if we're
out at a store or something running an
errand
he'll tell the workers you better watch
out for her because she steals
but do you understand how that might
make you feel like a criminal
exactly i mean i used to steal
oh yeah okay you used to steal what did
you
i was totally kidding around this is a
breakthrough i stole skittles from
blockbuster i stole a stick of gum once
from the
uh market i stole a bracelet from
express i stole another bracelet from
express hat someone told me to return it
i stole a headband from urban outfitters
once i stole a hat
okay and this this list doesn't so
there's some validity this is a this is
a
crime spree that the hillside strangler
would envy
we are pals and this works for us it's
sick
it's wrong very little is accomplished
very very little yeah it's insanity and
it should be stopped
it's your job to stop it would you like
me to fire you
i think we should both be fired well
this is great
you're happy now you did this i didn't
do it you did it
i'm gonna get a job at a burger king and
you're gonna be my assistant and crush
it at burger king
hey uh
quick personal note i think sona is due
to deliver
twins in like a week so
yeah and uh
uh we're very excited for her and we
love her to death uh and you know what's
amazing about sona just again on a
personal note uh
she is always herself you know most
people you put a camera on them
and they change they they add a little
something that
sona you could put her in you know
that's sona
radio city music hall and you could
bring her out there in front of
thousands of people and have it be the
most watched television event
and she'd be like what's up what the
[ __ ] going on you know and
[Laughter]
and she'd be charming and hilarious she
really i've never met anybody like that
before